it's the latest wave of massive attacks
against Kiev 40 drone attacks which
without a missiles the blender missiles
it does appear to be just drone attacks
um it's no coincidence and actually this
it happens on the anniversary of the
formation of Kiev which was some 1541
years ago normally on this day it's
celebrated by Street parties and stuff
like that in Kiev as it is it's a bit
more muted today but it almost certainly
irritates Russia because it's part of
the Ukrainian nationalism and therefore
it's no great surprise that that's why
they've been targeting Kiev itself there
are a total of 54 drone attacks they
were targeting kharkiv and the neat Pro
as well as around the country 52 of
those apparently were shot down but
inevitably get some get through uh one
person killed three injured and here's
some of the footage from Kiev itself it
looks very superficial but it's quite
extensive the damage and that's why
we've had quite a lot of casualties and
Sean what I mean what we're hearing also
that Russia now claiming to be able to
shoot down long range you Ukrainian
missiles how could this impact things
then moving forward it's all part of the
information award that's going on so
Russia claims that it shot down two of
these missiles these are Storm Shadow
missiles that were given to Ukraine
earlier this year by the UK
um they're pretty fast they're pretty
difficult to shoot down but they've also
Russia's claimed that it shot down the
high Mars missile some missiles which
these what the Americans have given now
the reality is these are really
difficult to shoot down but never say
never what looks more likely though is
that Russia was somewhat frustrated that
it's kinzao missile which is on the
Russian aircraft that's near you there
this is the Hypersonic missile which was
described by Russia's President Putin as
being undefeatable then the Ukraine has
actually been able to shoot a lot of
these down and I think Russian
frustration means they now want to show
that they can shoot down some of the
West's weapons so they're claiming
they've shot down high miles and Storm
Shadow the reality is that we don't
really know what's going on here but
what has been clear is the West is West
weapons are providing asymmetric
advantage to Ukraine and definitely
worrying the Russians and Sean what's
the latest then on the counter-offensive
we're waiting for the start line and
everybody to rush across in fact from a
military perspective it normally starts
with phase zero we call it which is use
shape for the enemy um uh um landscape
so you're hitting the Russians behind
the front line it's now targeting the
oil facilities their rail infrastructure
their weapon storage that's already
started but what's interesting in the
news today was the Russian Ambassador
said that the Russia was ready to talk
and wanted to negotiate peace and also
by that the war could be over by
tomorrow now the harsh reality is this
rhetoric or real this has happened
before yeah um but the the normal
foundations for a negotiated settlement
are normally either both sides have
ground themselves to a halt exhausted
and therefore they're in a stalemate and
therefore it's a good opportunity to
talk clearly they're not in that
position at the moment or one of the
sides has actually achieved all its
objectives on the battlefield and then
says right with raised at all Russia
clearly either wants to take the whole
of Ukraine or at least the Don bass has
not achieved success yet
um president zlinski he's made clear he
wants to get rid of Russians out of
every corner of the soil and they're
just about to launch a spring offensive
so in reality neither side is anywhere
close we're nowhere near getting a
negotiated settlement yet and the real
story here is the Russian Ambassador is
just playing his part in a Russian
information campaign
very shallow absolutely absolutely Sean
thank you Sean Belvedere